خ
[Silence]
ش
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
وسلم الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد لا اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله محمد رسول الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الصلاه حي
على على
الملاقا الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر لا
اله
استقيم سو سوا الص
صفكم الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم و
الضالين امين
رب لا يحب الله الجهر
بالسوء من القول الا من ظلل وكان الله
سميعا عليما
ان تبدوا خيرا او تفوه او تعفوا عن
سوء
فان الله كان عفوا
قبيرا ان الذين يكفرون بالله ورسله
ويريدون ان
يفرقون
ويريدون ان يفرقون بين الله ورسله ويقولون
ويقولون نؤمن ببعض ونكفر ببعض ويريدون ان
يتخذوا بين ذلك
سبيلا ان الذين يكفرون بالله ورسله
ويفرقون ويريدون ان يفرقوا ويفرقون بين
الله ورسله
ويقولون
ان الذين يكفرون بالله ورسله ويريدون ان
يفرقوا بين الله ورسله ويقولون نؤمن ببعض
ونكفر
ببعض ويريدون ان يتخذوا بين ذلك سبيلا
ائك هم الكافرون حقا واعددنا ل ين عذابا
مبينا والذين امنوا بالله ورسله ولم
يفرقوا بين احد منهم
اولئك سوف يؤتيهم اجورهم وكان الله غفورا
رحيما يسال كاهر الكتاب ان تنزل عليهم
كتابا من السماء
فقد سالوا موسى اكثر من ذلك فقالوا ارنا
الله
جهره فاخذتهم الصاعقه
بقلبهم
ثم اقضوا العجل من بعد ما
جاءتهم البينات فعفونا عن
ذلك
واتينا موسى
سلطانا مبينا ورفعنا فوقهم الطور خذوا ما
اتيناكم ورفعنا فوقهم الطور بميثاقهم
وقلنا
لهم وقلنا لهم ادخلوا الباب
سجدا وقلنا لهم وقلنا لهم لا تعلوا في
السبت واخذنا
منهم ميث
الله
اكبر سمع الله لم
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
ام
فبما نقضهم ميثاقهم وكفرهم بايات الله
وقتلهم
الانبياء بغير حق وقولهم قلوبنا ظلف بل
طبع الله عليها بكفرهم فلا يؤمنون الا
قليلا وبكفرهم
وقولهم على مريم بهتانا
عظيما وقولهم انا قتلنا المسيح وقولهم انا
قتلنا المسيح عيسى ابن مريم رسول
الله وما قتلوه وما صلبوه ولكن شبه لهم
وان الذين اختلفوا فيه لفي شء منه ما لهم
به من علم
الا الا اتباع
الظن وما قتلوه يقيما
برفعه الله اليه وكان الله عزيزا حكيما
وان من اهل الكتاب الا
ليؤمنن به قبل
موته ويوم القيامه يكون عليهم
شهيدا فبطل ان الذين هادوا حرمنا عليهم
طيبات احلت لهم وبصدهم
عن سبيل الله
كثيرا واخذهم الربا وقدرهم عنه واكلهم
اموال الناس
بالباطل واعتدنا
للكافرين منهم عذابا اليما
لكن الراسخون في عين منهم
والمؤمنون
والمؤمنون يؤمنون بما انزل اليك وما انزل
من قبله
والمقيمين الصلاه والمؤتون الزكاه
والمؤمنون بالله واليوم
الاخر
اولئك
نيهم اجرا
عظيما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكب
الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكب الله
اكب
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه
وسلم
[Silence]
السلام
‏sign
‏now
[Silence]
sch
first
comp
[Silence]
‏tak
‏care ‏right
now having
stud care of also not simple so we are
taking ed very seriously and foll the
curum that is avilable to us best that
avilable us run a
scho something
8000 based this year so if you looking
at this number a h number
[Silence]
‏pr
grly
‏no name
any
[Silence]
simp
that
make
[Silence]
‏and
‏are
[Silence]
ت
‏make
ely
that question
as
[Silence]
‏make
اسلامكم
[Silence]
‏comm ‏to take that you would you like
to see that
happ want to see that
happ to tell you that without any m from
your
own you can a and the this prr
work sch you know ta you can the you get
100%
[Silence]
1 ‏isic
ed
[Silence]
‏ed
‏to
[Silence]
استق
استقيم الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مك يوم الدين اياك
نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ان اوحينا اليك كما اوحينا الى نوح
والنبيين من
بع واوحينا الى ابراهيم واسماعيل واسحاق
ويعقوب
والاسباط والاسباط وعيسى وايوب ويوس
وهارون
وسليمان
واتينا داوود
سبورا ورسلا قد قصصناهم عليك من قبل ورسلا
لم نقصصهم عليك وكلم الله موسى
تكليما رسلا مبشرين
ومنفر
ل لانا يكون للناس على الله حجه بعد الرسل
وكان الله عزيزا حكيم
لكن الله يشهد بما انزل اليك
انزله
بعلم
والملائكه
يشهدون وكف بالله
شهيدا ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
قد ضلوا ضلالا
بعيدا ان ان الذين كفروا وظلموا لم يكن
الله يغفر لهم لم يكن الله ليغفر لهم ولا
ليهديهم
طريقا الا طريق جهنم خالدين فيها
ابدا وكان ذلك على الله
يثيرا يا ايها
الناس الرسول بالحق من ربكم فامنوا خيرا
لكم وان تكفروا فان لله ما في السماوات
وما في
الارض وان تكفرون ان بالله ما في السماوات
والارض
ولا عليما
حكيما يا اهل الكتاب لا توا دينكم ولا
تقولوا على الله الا
الحق انما الذير عيسى ابن مريم رسول الله
وكلمته القاها الى مريم وكلمته القاها الى
مريم
وروحه
فاهوا بالله وانصره
انه خيرا لكم
فامنوا بالله ورسله ولا تقولوا ثلاثه
انوا خيرا لكم انما الله
اله
واحد
سبحانه ان يكون له ولد له ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وكفى بالله وكيلا
لن
يستنكف المسيح ان يكون عبدا
لله ولا
الملائكه لن
يستنكف المسيح ان يك دا لله ولا
الملائكه
المقربون ومن يستنكف عن عبادته ويستكبر
فسرهم اليه جميعا فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات فيوفيهم
اجورهم فيوفيهم
اجورهم
ويزيدهم من
فضره
وان الذين استنكفوا واستكبروا لعذبهم
عذابا اليما في عذبهم عذابا اليما ولا
يجدونهم من دون الله وليا ولا
نصيرا يا ايها الناس قد
جاءكم برهان
منكم
وانزلنا اليكم نورا
مبينا فاما الذين امنوا بالله
واعتصموا به
فسيدخلهم
فسيدخلهم في
رحمه منه وفق ويهديهم اليه صراطا
مستقيما
يستون قل الله يؤتيكم تلك
لاله قل الله يفتيكم
بالكلاله ان امر ليس له
ولد وله قطب فلها نصف ما ترى وهو يلدها ان
لم يكن لها
ولد فان كانتا فوق
اثنتين فان كانت اثنتين فلهما السران مما
تر وان كانوا اخوه
رجالا ون
سء فان كانت ت اثنتين فلهما الثلثان منما
ترك وان كانوا اخوه
رجالا
ونساء فللذكر مثل حظ
الانثيين يبين الله لكم ان
تضلوا والله بكل شيء
عليم الله
اكبر سمع
الله
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اوفوا
بالعقود والت لكم بهيمه الانعام الا ما
يتلى عليكم الا ما يتلى عليكم غير محل
الصيد وانتم حرم ان الله يحف ما
يريد يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تحلوا عائر
الله ولا الشهر الحرام ولا الشهر الحرام
ولا الهدي ولا
القلائد
ولاين البيت الحرام يبتغون فضلا من ربهم
ورضوانا واذا حللتم فاصطادوا
ولا يجرمنكم
شنان قوم انص دوكم عن المسجد الحرام ان
تعتدوا
وتعاونوا على البر والتقوى ولا تعاونوا
على الاثم
والعدوان واتقوا الله ان الله شديد
العقاب حرمت عليكم العيثه والده ولحم
الخنزير وما اهل لغير الله به الم خقه
والموقوذه
والمترديه
والنطيحه وما اكل السبع الا ما
ذكيتم الا ما ذكيتم وما ذبح على النصب وان
تستقسموا
بالازلام ذلكم رزق اليوم يئس الذين كفروا
من دينكم فلا تحشرهم
واخشون اليوم اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت
عليكم نعمتي ورضيت لكم الاسلام دينا فمل
الطر في مخمصه غير متجانف لثم فان الله
غفور
رحيم يسالونك ماذا اكلل
لهم يسالونك ماذا احل لهم
ق يسالونك ماذا احل لهم قل احل لكم
الطيبات وما علمتم من الجوارح
مكلبين مكلبين
تعلمونهن مما علمكم
الله فكلوا مما امسكن عليكم واذكروا اسم
الله عليه واتقوا الله ان الله سريع
الحساب اليوم احل لكم الطيبات
وطعام الذين اوتوا الكتاب وطعام الذين
اوتوا الكتاب حل لكم وطعامكم حل
لهم والمحصنات من المؤمنات والمحصنات
من الذين اوتوا
الكتاب والم الصلاه من الذين اوتوا الكتاب
من قبلكم اذا
اتيتموهن
اجورهم محصنين غير مساكين ولا متخذين
ودان ومن يكفر بالايمان فقد حبق عمله وهو
في الاخره من الخاسرين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا قمتم الى الصلاه
فاغسلوا وجوهكم وايديكم الى المرافق
وامسحوا برؤوسكم
وارجلكم الى
الكعبين وان كنتم جندا
فطهر وان كنتم مرضى او على سك او جاء احد
منكم او جاء احد منكم من
الغائب او لا نستم
النساء او لامستم
النساء فلم تجدوا
ماء
فتيمموا صعيدا طيبا فامسحوا بوجوهكم
وايديكم
منه ما يريد الله ليجعل عليكم من حرج
ولكن ولكن يريد ليطهركم وليتم نعمته عليكم
لعلكم
تشكرون واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم
وميثاقه الذي
واثقكم به اذ قلتم سمعنا
واطعنا واتقوا الله ان الله عليم بذات
الصور يا ايها الذين امنوا كونوا قوامين
لله شهداء
بالفسق ولا
يجرمنكم
شنان قوم على الا
تعدلوا اعدلوا واقرب للتقوى
واتقوا الله ان الله خبير بما
تعملون وعد الله الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات لهم
مغفره واجر عظيم والذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا اولئك اصحاب الهنين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم اذ هم قوم ان يبسط اذ هم قوم ان
يبسطوا اليكم ايديهم فف ايديهم
عنكم واتقوا الله وعلى الله فل
يتوكلوا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
خ
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
ام
ولقد اخذ الله ميثاق بني
اسرائيل وبعثنا منهم اثني عشر
نقي وقال الله اني معكم لئن اقمتم الصلاه
واتيتم الزكاه
وامنتم برسلي وعزرتموهم
واقرضتم الله قرضا حسنا
لاكفرن عن
سيئاتكم
لاكفرن عنكم سيئاتكم
ولادخل
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار فمن كفر بعد ذلك منكم فقد ظل
سواء
السبيل فبما نقضهم ميثاقهم
لعناهم وجعلنا قلوبا قاسيه يعرفون الكلم
عن
مواضعه ونسوا حظا مما تترون به ولا
تزال على
خائنه منهم الا قليلا منهم فاعف عنهم
واسبح ان الله يحب
المحسنين ومن الذين ق قالوا انا نصارى
اخذنا ميثاقهم فنسوا حظا مما ذكروا به
فنسوا حظا مما ذكروا به فاغرينا بينهم
العداه
والبغضاء الى يوم
القيامه وسوف ينبئهم الله بما كانوا
يصنعون يا يا اهل الكتاب قد
جاءكم رسولنا يبين لكم كثيرا مما كنتم
تخفون من الكتاب ويعفوا عن
كثير قد
جاءكم من الله نور
وكتاب
مبين يهدي به الله من اتبع رضوانه سبل
السلام ويخرجهم من الظلمات الى النور
باذنه ويهديهم الى صراط
مستقيم لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو
المسيح ابن مريم قل فمن يملك من الله شيئا
ان اراد ان يهلك المسيح ابن مريم وام
ومن في الارض
جميعا ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما
بينهما يخلق ما
يشاء والله على كل شيء
قدير وقالت اليهود
والنصارى نحن
ابناء الله
واحباؤه
قل فلم
يعذبكم
بذنوبكم بل انتم بشر ممن خلق يغفر لمن
يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء ولله ملك السماوات والارض وما بينه
واليه
المصير يا اهل الكتاب قد ق
جاءكم رسولنا على ف قد
جاءكم رسولنا يبين لكم على فتره من الرسل
ان تقولوا ما
جاءها من بشير ولا نذير فقد
جاءكم بشير ونذير والله على كل شيء
قدير واذ قال موسى لقومه يا قوم اذكروا
نعمه الله عليكم اذ جعل فيكم
انبياء
وجعلكم
ملوكا وجعلكم ملوكا
وداكم ما لم يؤت احدا من
العالمين يا قوم ا الارض المقدسه التي كتب
الله لكم ولا تر توا على
ادباركم
فتنقلبوا
خاسرين قالوا يا موسى ان فيها قوما
جبارين وانا لن ندخلها حتى يخرجوا منها
فان يخرجوا منها فانا
داخلون قال رجلان من الذين يخافون انعم
الله عليه ادخلوا عليهم
الباب فاذا دخلتموه فانكم
غالبون وعلى الله فتوكلوا ان
كنتم
مؤمنين قالوا يا موسى انا لن ندخلها ابدا
ما ناموا فيها فاذهب انت وربك فقج لا
اناما
قارون قال رب اني لا املك الا نفسي واخي
فافرق بيننا وبين القوم
الفاسقين قال
فانها محرمه عليهم اربعين سنه يهون في
الارض فلا تاس على القوم
الفاسقين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله ال رحمن ال
رحيم لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم
ضالين
امين وادل عليه فن ادم بالحق اذ قربا
قربانا فتقبل من احدهما ولم يتقبل من
الاخر قال
لاقتلنك قال انما يتقبل الله من
المتقين
فان بسطت الي يدك لتقتلني ما انا بلا
سق اليك لاقد لك اني اخاف الله رب
العالمين اني اريد ان
تموء باذني واثمك فتكون من اصحب
النار وذلك
جزاء الظالمين
فطوعت له نفسه قت اخيه فقتله فاصبح من
الخاسرين فبعث الله غرابا يبحث في الارض
ليليه كيف يوالي
سوداي قال يا ويلنا اعجزت ان اكون مثل هذا
الغراب فاواه سوءه اهل فاصبح من ال
الناين من اجل ذلك كتبنا على بني
اسرائيل انه من قتل نفسا بغير نفس او فساد
في الارض
فكانما قتل الناس
جميعا ومن احياها
فكانما احي الناس
جميعا ولقد جاء
جاءتهم رسلنا
بالبينات ثم ان كثيرا منهم بعد ذلك في
الارض لمسرفون
انما
جزاء الذين يحاربون الله ورسوله ويسعون في
الارض ويسعون في الارض فسادا ان
يقتلوا انما جزاء الذين يحاربون الله
ورسوله ويسعون في الارض فساد ان يقتلوا او
يصلبوا او تقطع ايديهم
وارجلهم من خلاف او
ينفوا من الارض ذلك لهم خز في الدنيا ولهم
في الاخره عذاب عظيم
الا الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك واصحوا فان
الله غفور
الرحيم الا الذين كبوا من قبل ان تقدروا
عليهم فاعلموا ان الله غفور
رحيم يا ايها
الذي
يا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وتقوا
اليه الوسيله وجاهدوا في سبينه لعلكم
تفلحون ان الذين كفروا لو ان لهم ما في
الارض جميعا ومثله ا ليفتدوا
به يوم القيامه ما تقبل منه ما تقب لل
منهم ولهم عذاب
اليم يريدون ان يخرجوا من النار وما هم
بخارجين منها ولهم عذاب
مبين والسارق والسارقه فقعوا ايديهما
تساء بما كسبا نكان من الله والله عي
حكيم فمن ء من بعد ظلمه واصلح فان الله
يتوم عليه ان الله غفور
رحيم الم تعلم ان الله له ملك السماوات
والارض يذب من
يشاء ويغفر لمن
يشاء
والله على كل شيء
قدير الله
اكبر سمع الله
لده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏ja
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏back
[Silence]
اليم بسم الله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى ال ومن ولاء
ومن اللهم صل وسلم
علىه
صحس صلى الله عليه
وسلم رول صل علسلم
مه بن
سعد رول عل وسلم
[Silence]
سهال
الله
مح رسول الله صلى
علم ‏back now interesting situation when
they
are
from beautiful
thing an ey on that everything that is
عل
all
[Silence]
عبد
عليه
‏first open heart surgy i
call where the heart
tak جبيل
[Silence]
عليه
‏you
[Silence]
ح عبد
المطلب
عليهه
واللام he not looking normal
exper and they come and and
make and
[Silence]
ملام
عليه الصلاه
[Silence]
والسلام
رسول الله صل علسلم ان شا
الله عليه الصه
والسلامه عليهه والسلام عليهه
والسلام
عبد
الله
ح ان شاء الله تالى
سبحان
علس
[Silence]
الصلاه
والسلام ان شاء
اللهى
علسلام الله
[Silence]
سحال
اللهبه ال الاحد رول
اللهه اله الا الله محد رسول
اللهفي الاخره حسنه و عب النار وق عذاب
القبر ع
جنم
وسح الال ربنا اغفر لنا ولوالدينا
والمسلمين والمسلمات والمؤمنين المؤمنات
الاحياء من الاموات ربنا تقبل من السميع
العليم التواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمين ارحم الراحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الرسول لا يحزنك الذين
يسارعون في كفر من الذين قالوا امنا
بافواههم ولم تؤمن
قلوبهم ومن الذين هادوا سماعون للكذب
سماعون لقوم اخرين لم
ياتوك يحرفون الكلم من بعد
مواضعه يقولون ان اوتيتم هذا فخذوه وان لم
تؤتوا
فاحذروا ومن يرد الله فتنته فلن تملك له
من الله
شيئا
اولئك الذين لم يرد الله ان يطهر قلوبهم
لهم في الدنيا خزي ولهم في الاخره عذاب
عظيم سماعون للكذب
اكالون للسح
فان
جاؤوك فاحكم بينهم او اعرض عنهم وان تعرض
عنهم فلن يضروك شيئا وان حكمت فاحكم بينهم
بالقسط ان الله يحب
المقسطين وكيف يحكمونك وعندهم التوراه
فيها ح حكم الله ثم يتولون من بعد ذلك وما
اولئك
بالمؤمنين انا انزلنا التوراه فيها هدى
ونور يحكم بها
النبيون الذين اسلموا للذين
هادوا يحكم بها النبيون الذين اسلموا
للذين هادوا والربان يون والاحبار بما
استحفظوا من كتاب الله وكانوا عليه
شهداء فلا تخشوا الناس واخشون ولا تشتروا
باياتي ثمنا
قليلا ومن لم يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الكافرون وكتبنا عليهم فيها ان النفس
بالنفس والعين بالعين
والانف بالانف والاذن بالاذن والسن
بالسن والسن بالسن والجروح
قصاص فمن تصدق به فهو كفاره له ومن لم
يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الظالمون وقفينا على اثارهم بعيسى ابن
مريم مصدقا لما بين يديه من التوراه
واتيناه الانجيل فيه هدى
ونور ومصدقا لما بين يديه من التوراه وهدى
وموعظه
للمتقين وليحكم اهل الان الجيل بما انزل
الله فيه ومن لم يحكم بما انزل الله
فاولئك هم
الفاسقون
وانزلنا اليك الكتاب بالحق مصدقا لما بين
يديه من الكتاب ومهيمنا
عليه فاحكم بينهم بما انزل الله ولا تتبع
اهواءهم عما
جاءك من
الحق لكل جعلنا منكم شرعه
ومنهاجا ولو شاء الله لجعلكم
امه واحده ولكن ليبلوكم فيما
اتاكم فاستبقوا الخي
الى الله مرجعكم جميعا
فينبئكم بما كنتم فيه
تختلفون وان احكم بينهم بما انزل الله ولا
تتبع
اهواءهم
واحذرهم واحذرهم ان يفتنوك عن بعض ما انزل
الله
اليك فان تولوا فاعلم انما يريد الله ان
يصيبهم ببعض
ذنوبهم وان كثيرا من الناس
لفاسقون افحكم الجاهليه
يبغون ومن احسن من الله حكما لقوم
يوقنون الله اكبر الله اك بك
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
سبحان
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين امين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا اليهود
والنصارى
اولياء بعضهم
اولياء بعض ومن
يتولهم منكم فانه منهم ان الله لا يهدي
القوم
الظالمين فترى الذين في قلوبهم مرض
يسارعون فيهم يقولون نخشى ان تصيبنا
دائره فعسى الله ان ياتي بالفتح او امر من
عنده فيصبحوا على ما اسروا في انفسهم
نادمين ويقول الذين امنوا اهؤلاء
الذين اقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم انهم
لمعكم حبطت اعمالهم فاصبحوا
خاسرين يا ايها الذين امنوا من يرتد منكم
عن دينه فسوف ياتي الله بقوم يحبهم
ويحبونه فسوف ياتي الله بقوم يحبهم
ويحبونه اذله على المؤمنين اعزه على
الكافرين يجاهدون في سبيل الله ولا يخافون
لوم
تلائم ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله واسع
عليم انما وليكم الله رسوله والذين
امنوا الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون الزكاه
وهم
راكعون ومن يتولى الله ورسوله والذين
امنوا فان حزب الله هم
الغالبون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
الذين اتخذوا دينكم هزوا ولعبا
من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم والكفار
اولياء واتقوا الله ان كنتم
مؤمنين واذا ناديتم الى الصلاه اتخذوها
هزوا
ولعبا ذلك
بانهم قوم لا
يعقلون قل يا اهل الكتاب هل ينقمون منا
الا ان امنا بالله وما انزل الينا وما
انزل من قبل وان اكثركم
فاسقون قل هل انبئكم بشر من ذلك مثوبه عند
الله من لعنه الله وغضب
عليه وجعل منهم القرده والخنازير و د
الطاغوت
اولئك شر مكانا واضل عن
سواء
السبيل واذا
جاؤوكم قالوا امنا وقد دخلوا بالكفر وهم
قد خرجوا به والله اعلم بما كانوا
يكتمون وترى كثيرا منهم يسارعون في الاثم
والعدوان واكلهم السحت لبئس ما كانوا
يعملون لولا ينهاهم
الربانيون والاحبار عن قولهم الاثم واكلهم
السحت لبئس ما كانوا
يصنعون وقالت اليهود يد الله
مغلوله غلت ايديهم ولعنوا بما
قالوا بل يداه
مبسوطتان ينفق كيف
يشاء
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا
وكفرا والقينا بينهم العداوه
والبغضاء الى يوم
القيامه كل ما اوقدوا نارا للحرب اطفاها
الله ويسعون في الارض
فسادا والله لا يحب
المفسدين ولو ان اهل الكتاب امنوا واتقوا
لكفرنا عنهم سيئاتهم ولادخل اناهم جنات
النعيم ولو انهم اق قاوا التوراه
والانجيل وما انزل اليهم من ربهم لاكلوا
من فوقهم ومن تحت
ارجلهم منهم امه
مقتصده وكثير منهم
ساء ما
يعملون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعب عبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الرسول بلغ ما انزل اليك من
ربك وان لم تفعل فما بلغت
رسالته والله يعصمك من
الناس ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين قل يا اهل الكتاب لستم على شيء
حتى تقيموا التوراه
والانجيل وما انزل اليكم من
ربكم
وليزيدن كثيرا منهم ما انزل اليك من ربك
طغيانا
وكفرا فلا تاس على القوم
الكافرين ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا
والصابئون
والنصارى من امن بالله واليوم الاخر وعمل
صالحا فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون لقد اخذنا ميثاق بني
اسرائيل وارسلنا اليهم
رسلا كلما
جاءهم رسول بما لا تهوى انفسهم فريقا
كذبوا
وفريقا
يقتلون وحسبوا الا تكون فتنه فعموا وصموا
ثم تاب الله عليهم ثم عموا وصموا كثير
منهم والله بصير بما
يعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله اكبر
الله الله
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لقد كثر الذين قالوا ان الله هو
المسيح ابن مريم وقال المسيح يا بني
اسرائيل اعبدوا الله ربي
وربكم انه من يشرك بالله فقد حرم الله
عليه الجنه وماواه
النار وما
للظالمين من
انصار لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله ثالث
ثلاثه قل فمن يملك من الله شيئا ان اراد
ان يهلك المسيح ابن مريم وامه ومن في
الارض
جميعا كفر الذين
قالوا وما
من لقد كفر الذين قالوا ان الله ثالث
ثلاثه وما من اله الا اله واحد وان لم
ينتهوا عما يقولون
ليمسن الذين كفروا منهم عذاب
اليم افلا يتوبون الى الله
ويستغفرونه والله غفور
رحيم ما المسيح ابن مريم الا رسول قد خلت
من قبله الرسل وامه
صديقه كانا ياكلان
الطعام انظر كيف نبين لهم الايات ثم انظر
يؤفكون قل اتعبدون من دون الله ما لا يملك
لكم ضرا ولا نفعا والله هو السميع
العليم قل يا اهل الكتاب لا تغلوا في
دينكم غير
الحق ولا تتبعوا
اهواء قوم قد ضلوا من قبل ضلوا كثيرا
وضلوا عن
سواء
السبيل لعن الذين كفروا من بني
اسرائيل على لسان داوود وعيسى ابن
مريم ذلك بما عصوا وكانوا
يعتدون كانوا لا يتناهون عن
منكر فعلوا
لبئس ما كانوا
يفعلون ترى كثيرا منهم يتولون الذين كفروا
لبئس ما قدمت لهم انفسهم ان سخط الله
عليهم وفي العذاب هم
خالدون ولو كانوا يؤمنون بالله والنبي وما
انزل اليهم اتخذوهم
اولياء ما اتخذوهم
اولياء
ولكن كثيرا منهم
فاسقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
ت
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام صلاه
الوتر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الم تر كيف فعل ربك باصحاب
الفيل الم يجعل كيدهم في
تضليل وارسل عليهم طير
ابابيل
ترميهم
بحجاره من
سجيل فجعلهم
كعصف
ماكول الله اكبر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا ولك الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
لايلاف
قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي
اطعمهم من
جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر اللهم
صل اللهم
صل
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
اكبر الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر الله
اك
سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملء السماوات وملء الارض وملء
ما بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اللهم
صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اللهم انا نسالك التقى والهدى والعفاف
والغنى اللهم انا نسالك التقى والهدى
والعفاف والغنى اللهم دبر لنا فانا لا
نحسن التدبير واختر لنا فانا لا نحسن
الاختيار اللهم نقنا من خطايانا كما ينقى
الثوب الابيض من الدنس اللهم اغسلنا من
خطايانا
بالماء والثلج
والبرد اللهم انا نعوذ بك من درك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء وشماته الاعداء ونعوذ بك
اللهم من السلب بعد
العطاء ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من القوم
الكافرين
ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا انك على كل
شيء
قدير اللهم انا نسالك باسمك الاعظم الذي
اذا دعيت به اجبت واذا سئلت به
اعطيت ان تنصر الاسلام
والمسلمين وان ترفع رايه العز والدين
اللهم كن لاخواننا المستضعفين في كل م
امين وانصر اخواننا المرابطين في غزه وفي
باقي الارض يا رب يا رب
العالمين اللهم سدد رميهم اللهم اهلك عدوك
وعدوهم اللهم عليك بكل من اذاهم ولو بكلمه
يا رب العالمين اللهم اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من خوف اللهم داوي
جرحاهم واشف مرضاهم وارحم امواتهم اللهم
عجل بالفرج لهم يا رب
العالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من
الظالمين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
سبحان
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
شا
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
الله يزيك
حبيبي